what do you get when you cross Twilight
and the village crap Red Riding Hood is
really just a cross between Twilight and
the village it's really going to appeal
to that teen fan base that goes nuts
over the Disney Channel and Justin
Bieber and the Twilight movies and all
this stuff and this film really is just
a cross between Twilight in the village
I am NOT a Twilight fan at all I did
like the village though this don't
follows a character played by Amanda
Seyfried she lives in an ancient village
with her family and there's a wolf on
the loose the big bad wolf as the
classic tale always tells and the
townspeople are trying to hunt this wolf
that's picking off the people one by one
and eventually they call him Gary Oldman
who's like this priest who takes control
of the village and creates utter chaos
amongst the village and he doesn't have
any idea what he's doing he's just
unlike some crusade to find this thing
and kill it he's just as much of a
villain as the wolf Amanda Seyfried is
in love with some boy but he can't have
her though because he's back in the
olden days you know girls were set up
with men and she set up with another guy
who loves her but she doesn't love him
as you can tell I didn't like this film
it comes from the director of Twilight
believe it or not and Twilight was
actually better I'm just getting very
sick and tired of a pattern that I've
been seeing lately in a lot of films and
what it is is that so many films now are
no longer art people don't make films to
make art anymore they just make films to
make money and this film is clearly
going for that fanbase that young teen
demographic more than likely all female
the kind of people who go nuts for
Twilight and pay tons and tons of money
for it even though it's not even very
good it's really bothersome because I
love filmmaking so my subscribers may
not know that I
independent filmmaker and I love to make
short films I have a channel based on
that in my channel recommendation box
when I see a director or a writer or
producer or somebody who just always is
making movies to just appeal to some
demographic they're not thinking of
making movie as an art form anymore or
as a way to give good messages to people
and no it's just it's just make money
that's all this film is two giant ripoff
of Twilight in the village and other
movies that aren't even all that great I
don't understand why it keeps happening
I've told you some of the bad some more
of the bat is just the cheesiness the
sappiness the soap opera stuff that's
going on it's just it's so fake the good
of this film amanda seyfried she is a
good actress she's talented she's very
pretty she does a good job in this film
mustering up emotion for scenes that
were written as if it was made for some
elementary school play or something the
actual wolf creature very good special
effects there were a few scenes with the
wolf that I that was actually really
into and were well done some of the
colors in the film are very nice there
are some good shots in this film the
director of photography did a pretty
good job with some of the scenic shots
however so much of the village actually
looked like it was CGI and not an actual
place whereas in like whatever my Shemin
made his film the village he actually
built a real village in an actual
location where it looks like so much of
this is just a set you know what I mean
and it's just so unconvincing they took
a little out of a Little Red Riding Hood
title this is supposed to be for older
teens or something but the story the
script the overall feel the film so
juvenile so maybe they should put little
back in the title I'm gonna give a
little spoiler here so just to warn you
I'm going to spoil a scene in this film
there's actually a scene where she does
the whole oh grandma what big eyes you
have
oh grandpa what big ears you have I was
like ends up being a dream okay so yeah
there was an excuse for it to be weird
but the film is not horrible I went into
the film very sleepy and the film kept
my attention I didn't fall asleep the
movies just such a ploy it's just like a
way to rope an innocent girl
no idea what love is actually about and
I think it's some romance novel and it's
just it's so fake it's just a big
gigantic soap opera with a creature I am
Number Four was a romance with an alien
I liked that film but come on you know
that it was definitely had some
inspiration from the whole Twilight
thing beastly you know it was abusing
the beast type of thing but it was a
romance with a very disfigured looking
man now this romance with a wolf you
know man thing going on it's just it's
dumb I'm not going to spoil it but the
ending of this film you could read into
it so wrongly in such a creepy way that
it is just wrong on so many levels I
really hope it's not the filmmakers of
suggesting and I'm sure they probably
weren't suggesting what it looks like
they're suggesting but at the end of
this film when the film ended I had an
expression on my face kind of like this
Red Riding Hood has talented actors in
it Gary Oldman is a good actor however
his character is very overblown here
Amanda Seyfried is also a good actress
then there are some good visuals there
are a few entertaining scenes but the
overall just the fakeness and that we're
trying to buy off teens from stuff they
already like just makes this film just
so-so not worth seeing
please don't see it I'm going to get red
riding a 2 out of 4 stars don't check
out this film